your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
laureates ladies and gentlemen the in
stove era a focus on tiara move out
please target an efficient it is a great
honor to introduce the Nobel laureate in
physics professor emeritus Peter Higgs
your Majesties your other Highnesses
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen
it is a great honor for also on Leah and
me to receive the Nobel Prize in Physics
and we wish to express our sincere
gratitude to the Royal Swedish Academy
of Sciences and the Noble Foundation it
is a matter of great regret for both of
us that Robert broke did not live to
share the prize with us the fact that it
has been awarded to just the two of us
implicitly recognises his contribution
as is right however it should be
remembered that the three of us were not
the only theorists who contributed to
the elucidation of what is now called
the beh mechanism about fifty years ago
the long time gap between the
theoretical work and the award of the
prize is largely a consequence of the
difficulty of performing the experiments
needed to detect the new particle as an
obsessional feature of our theory more
than 30 years of work on the development
of accelerators detectors and computer
programs have culminated in the
discovery claim made by CERN in July
2012 it was a great achievement by all
the people involved and we are grateful
to them for enabling us to be here today